[Music]
in our morning rounds a study out today
highlights the impact of sleep on our
memory research reveals that as we age
brainwaves become unsynchronized because
of that the brain fails to hit the Save
button to keep new memories while we
sleep the report also points to a new
treatment for boosting brain power among
the elderly this could help the
estimated 6 million Americans with
Alzheimer's or mild cognitive impairment
Matthew Walker co-authored the study his
new book is called why we sleep
unlocking the power of sleep and dreams
it's published by Scribner that's an
imprint of Simon & Schuster which is a
division of CBS Matthew heads UC
Berkeley sleep and neuro imaging lab and
joins us once again at the table good to
see you
thank you very much last time you were
here Matthew I felt like dead men
walking and something tells me I'm not
gonna feel much better after this I'm so
sorry I am too I do but what did you
discover about the link between sleep
sleep and your memory so what we found
is that in young healthy adults the deep
sleep brain waves are perfectly
synchronized in time and that
synchronization helps you essentially
hit the Save button on new memories but
as we get older those deep sleep brain
waves become mistimed so it's almost a
little bit like a drummer who is just
one beat off the rhythm yes and so you
can't cement those memories into the
brain so you end up forgetting the next
morning rather than remembering Matthew
what age are we talking about here it's
a definition of aging yeah let's be
clear it's a progressive decline here in
this study we were looking at people who
are 65 and older and that's where we saw
a marked change in that synchrony of
brain rhythms but we do know that deep
sleep decline starts even in your 30s
into your 40s why does it decline well
part of the reason is that the deep
sleep generating center of the brain
which sits just above your eyes in the
middle of the brain that actually starts
to deteriorate we lose brain cells there
as we get older and as you lose those
brain cells
you can't generate that same depth and
quality of sleep nor can you synchronize
those brainwaves either anything we can
do to get the drummer back on time to
get the synchronicity back well that's
exactly what we're hoping to do we're
she trying to develop new electrical
brain stimulation technology at my sleep
center to see if we can actually try to
resynchronize those brain waves almost
acting like an electrical metronome to
actually amplify those deep sleep brain
waves resynchronize them and give back
some deep sleep quality to older adults
and maybe Salvage aspects of learning
and memory so last time you were here
you said adults all need at least eight
hours of sleep a night so we've all been
wearing the trackers I noticed in four
nights yep and so these are the results
because you said short sleep equals a
short lives so Nora's up first she slept
an hour an average of six hours and 36
minutes these last three days from
Sunday to Thursday Jon slept an average
of 6 hours and 16 minutes
I slept an average of well there's 4
hours and 25 minutes oh my goodness look
at that tell me where you live on you're
coming to your sleep intervention every
way no I'm so worried about you Gayle
very it is talking about your life and
your health here but for the life of me
I don't know anybody that works to shift
I know I need to do better but I don't
know what can we do and I'm not just
talking about me I'm talking about
everybody because we get like 4 o'clock
in the same time 3:30
I mean it's desperately difficult we
need to prioritize sleep we need an
attitude change in society we know that
if you're getting seven hours of sleep
or less you are at significantly higher
risk of developing Alzheimer's disease
you are going to be at almost a 200
percent higher risk of developing some
form of cancer if you're getting six
hours of sleep or less we also know that
those who are getting six hours or less
have a 210 percent increased risk of
having a heart attack or a stroke in
their lifetime so if you think there's a
stigma associated with sleep in some way
I I do I think we've I think sleep has
an image problem I think we chastise
people who get sufficient sleep we give
them this label of being slothful or
lazy and that has to change and it has
to change at the government level to
start with when was the last time that
any government first world nation
actually had a public health campaign
regarding sleep we have them for you
know drowsy driving we have
them for alcohol drugs you know public
health campaign here you think that's
necessary I think it's necessary in all
developed nations yeah and no one is
doing it we need that movement it's so
interesting because you you know as a
mother of three kids I can see when they
have like one or two hours less of sleep
how it completely affects their behavior
and so I've been very strict about
trying to get them to bed at the same
time every night because you it's so
radically apparent how it changes your
behavior in your mood and you they're
working I'm okay now but they're still
younger I don't have teenagers yes I
mean it's difficult but what you're
gifting them is probably the greatest
life insurance policy you could ever
imagine
yeah but we forget that with ourselves
very much hopefully my mother's
listening information mysteries yeah
thank you very much very much Matthew
Walker why we sleep is on sale wherever
you like to buy your books got lots
options there